aash to viva la aria a Bengali Hindu
ensuring district of Assam is anxious
her family is trying to piece together
why she was left out of last year's
draft list of Indian citizens in Assam
she was married at 13 and is literate
enough to just be able to write her name
her husband never went to school now
they're forced to father the complex
paperwork they may need to prove that
she's Indian state detain me I don't
know what I will do my children would
not have a mother I won't even be able
to see them Amina Haughton a Bengali
Muslim and her two sisters were also
left out of the draft list the 48 year
old says she's tired of being seen as an
outsider my father was born here
I was born here I was married here my
children were born here so why should I
be called a foreigner if Ashton Ebola
and Amina cotton don't make it to the
final list they will not be immediately
declared foreigners and subsequently
detained they can come to tribunals like
these with evidence to prove that
they're Indian but some legal experts
say that there are several challenges
that could lead to some serious errors a
mistake over a name cost 60 year old
madam allemande all three years of her
life and three birthdays of a
granddaughter she was locked in a
detention center for declared foreigners
instead of another woman long dead with
a similar name it's been a difficult
time I'm the only breadwinner of this
house my daughter is disabled but I was
forced to leave the two girls behind to
fend for themselves they didn't have
anyone on our side we have no one no
father no brother
but Rakhi is their Petrakis imbibed
disloyal things it's been an uphill
battle for women from vulnerable
communities to prove their citizenship
one document the girl will have I'm
illiterate I'm poor so what document I
give is a female what document I'll give
I don't have any documents
the government says more than 200
foreign tribunals will soon start
operating and all cases will be heard
land language and ethnicity lie at the
heart of a Sams debate on illegal
immigration for women like ash Timmy
Bala and others it's been a challenge
trying to weed out doubts over what ties
them to the country and the land they
were born in Priyanka Gupta al Jazeera
Barbado
Assam